[Applause]
Bob have you noticed that all the
designers nominated this year had to
research the clothing of Years Gone
by could have saved Time by checking my
closet oh come on now that t looks new
to me well it goes back first thing in
the
morning well then it deserves to have a
great evening for the best achievement
in costume design the nominees
are
Melena cananero for Chariots of
[Applause]
[Music]
Fire Tom ran for the French Lieutenant's
Woman anah Hill jamstone for rag
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Music]
earlyy Russell from
reds
Bob Macky for Penny's from
[Music]
heaven
[Applause]
[Music]
will you read the winner Morgan I hate
to make enemies it's okay I love to make
friends and the winner is Elena cananero
for Chariots of
[Music]
[Applause]
Fire well I'm very happy to be here
thank you very much and I want to thank
Hugh Hudson D patam Marshall Bell and I
also like to pay homage to my other
colleagues sherley Russell Tom ran anah
Hill Jackson Bob mcke because I think we
are all
marvelous but I've got
[Music]
[Applause]
it